welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of secret
Invasion Episode 2. Fury's got a home
life the Groot is loose and Roadie is
ready to carpet bomb us back to when he
was Terrence Howard who can we trust we
found so many details and Easter eggs
and connections that you might have
missed and thanks to Rocket money for
sponsoring today's vid more about them
in a minute and remember new rockstars
is now three channels this main channel
for these Easter egg breakdowns my
channel the Deep dive for deeper
analyzes of classic titles and the break
room which is the new home of our inside
Marvel reactions in the secret Invasion
after show so subscribe to all three and
you can support us with some scroll
inspired shirts at nerd riot.shop okay
the episode opens in Brixton a
neighborhood in London we actually saw a
poster last episode for a Brixton
Community Center Island art series and
the mural on the walls of this community
center may be depicting some of
brixton's afro-caribbean population
which it is known for actually in 1981
the Brixton riots occurred when some of
these young immigrants clashed with
police which had been using racist stop
and search policies so really setting
this immigrant story and Brixton comes
with some real world historical
parallels but this is in 1997 which
would be two years after the events of
Captain Marvel in 1995. this would be
early in Nick Fury's era of launching
his new Avengers Initiative before it
would be shut down by the world Security
Council leading up to the 2012 Avengers
events Fury deputizing these scroll
refugees might have been part of that
first wave plan of Avengers on Earth
this would be where he would make
mistakes he would improve upon with
shield in the Avengers and note that
with every Nick Fury transition he would
build things like helicarriers and now
saber aircraft and spacecraft to take
the fight more and more off the ground
Vara introduces Fury to Young gravic in
the New Avengers comics from 2015 Vara
is a name of a squirrel Cree hybrid one
of the Knights of the infinite who gets
saved by Young Avengers hulkling and
wicked hulklin is also half scroll and
Vara seems to be the same scroll that
Fury later marries Priscilla Fury played
by Charlene Woodard now Vara isn't
listed in the credits but this girl does
have a similar height and voice to that
of Woodard his parents were killed in
the last stand against the cree aren't
you forgetting something Fury does the
scroll gesture of touching foreheads
which he did with Talos last episode and
we saw Talos do with his family in
Captain Marvel Vara says gravic's
parents died in the last stand against
the cree in Captain Marvel we learned
that the Creed destroyed the squirrel
home world of scrollos after the
squirrels refused to submit to the rule
of the Korean Empire and we saw some of
that destruction and the escape in the
opening title imagery ever since the
Scrolls have been a nomadic race but the
squirrel in the cree remained locked in
a kind of Shadow war that was hinted at
in Spider-Man far from home I thought
Cree having sleeper cells was top secret
information Fury says he's a child well
he's a human eyes Talos last episode
indicated that the scroll maturation and
lifespan is different than that of
humanity they live much longer lives but
it sounds like they mature much sooner
so we can also apply that early maturity
to Gaia and Captain Marvel the moment
when she was on the space station and
saw some Cree get shot the violence she
saw was witnessed by someone with more
of an adult context of what it meant
notice how Vara is wearing this
interesting ring on her right hand we
don't see that ring on Priscilla's
finger later which is odd because
Priscilla's seems pretty strict about
the rings that these two have to wear
but maybe this old one represented a
union in her past life on scrollos Fury
asks the skulls to take on human faces
as he promises to find them a new home
using Earth as a refugee Colony will
also be with the asgardians of new
Asgard due in in-game and Thor 11
Thunder and in wakanda forever there was
a new sticker reporting that President
ritzen signed a trade agreement with new
Asgard and there was no expectation that
the asgardians assimilate or changed
anything about themselves is I guess
they look humanoid enough and drink as
guardian ale and eat Thanos themed ice
cream do Old Spice commercials so this
expectation for the squirrels represents
the way some ethnic and immigrant groups
are expected to hide or erase their
Heritage While others get to celebrate
theirs Soren here is played by Kate
Braithwaite in her scroll form and
Charlotte Baker in her human form and
Captain Marvel in a far from home she
was played by Sharon Flynn and that was
only ever a scroll form because we never
saw the human form besides Maria Hill in
the aftermath of the Russian Unity day
attack Maria Hill is definitely dead
folks since she does not revert here to
squirrel form I don't think there's any
hope for Tahiti from Agents of Shield
either this episode shows us her casket
with an American flag draped over it an
angry mother they would not go to these
dramatic lengths if they intended
Maria's cell death to be a fake out
let's not do the thing that we do in
every Marvel show and just overthink the
wrong things there's only six episodes
of this and obviously they're setting up
bigger Mysteries than this the AAR guy
that's the scroll Brogan and disguises
human says I'm an American I'm an
American
I'm an American yes he says I'm an
American over and over and over again
because Brogan really wants these
Russians to think it was an American who
did this to raise the tensions between
these Powers the guy who grabs Fury
shapeshifts back into Talus and I just
like visually how they use the rising
window to help with the visual effect of
the transition like by the time the
glass is up it's mostly just tell us but
with just a few final bits shifting left
disguised as a blonde woman Talos tells
the Russian soldiers that finding a
black American on train for Moscow to
Poland is less likely than finding
aliens really pushing the aliens Talos I
was reminded of how Eames an Inception
uses a blonde woman as a disguise to
trick Fisher based on the woman in the
red dress and the Matrix an Inception
also begins with a heist where in a
train car but the sign on the seat
behind Fury translates to Moscow to
Warsaw and the name of the train line
translates to Soaring owl an owl being
important imagery for Nick Fury as a
statue for his hidden camera lens spying
on Sonia fallsworth Fury tells Talos
about his childhood in Alabama taking
long train rides with his mom to Detroit
and having to ride in a segregated train
car and play a game called tell me
something I don't know at one time she
said
tell me something I don't know about you
and Susie me and Susie had a standing
game of doctor we've been playing behind
old man Jackson's Bond old man Jackson
uh not just Samuel L Jackson himself
Fury explains it whenever he'd say a
crazy lie that would tell his mom that
he was hiding a greater light this
recalls a story that Nick Fury told
about his grandpa back in Captain
America Winter Soldier every week some
punk would say what's in the bag
what'd he do
he chilling
a bunch of couple ones and a loaded 22
magnum Granddad love people
but he didn't trust them very much so
really it was Fury growing up in a
segregated South that gave him multiple
influences for not trusting people Fury
uses the game on Taylor's to learn that
all one million of the Scrolls that fled
scrollos after it was destroyed by the
crease settled on Earth and most of them
after the blip in the past few years
while Fury was on saber so that
post-blip Homeless crisis that affected
humans on Earth and all these other
titles is also affecting skrulls
particularly Across the Universe and I
point this out because nowhere is now
supposed to be a welcoming Refugee
colony in the MCU in space so why didn't
more squirrels go there well maybe some
did we do find out in a second about
other squirrel colonies but hey maybe
nowhere ain't that tolerant it is a
population mostly zandarians maybe
they're as intolerant as girls as
terrans are really I think it was just
Graphics appeal as a strong military
leader that attracted more squirrels to
Earth than to anywhere else Taylor says
that every squirrel that isn't an
emperor drogi's Colony they answered so
in the secret Invasion Comics Drogi fenu
edu spelled a little bit differently is
the head priest of Sciences who studied
captured members of the Illuminati and
discovers an events super Scrolls which
are Scrolls that can mimic the powers
and the appearances of those they
impersonate and that is what seems to be
the plot in the works revealed later
this episode we don't know if the
emperor Drogi that Talos mentions here
is part of that operation he just seems
to be the current Galactic leader of the
Scrolls and the fact that they call him
Emperor means that in their eyes they
still view their race as part of a
dynastic Empire they still have some
pride in their old ways Tayla says that
he wants humans and Scrolls to coexist
but Fury shoots back you almost can't
co-exist what are you trying to say loaf
you've been here wild enough to know
that we've been at war with each other
since we could walk upright there's not
enough room or Tolerance on this planet
for another species yeah Fury's
experiences with racism has set him up
with pessimism for human tolerance and
you cannot blame him back in London
Maria Hill's mother Elizabeth oversees
the transfer over Corps straight to the
American flag there's another woman with
her dressed in civilian attire not sure
who this is maybe her friend or a
partner or someone provided by the US
government to be a kind of Greek
counselor not really sure but Fury
having to face his grieving mother for
one reminds me of Brody and Jaws facing
Mrs Keaton but in the MCU totally
reminds me of Tony Stark having to face
Miriam sharp in Captain America Civil
War it's just rare that we meet the
parents of these people that are killed
in the conflicts it's what sobers up
these MCU Heroes to take responsibility
for all their avengering also Fury is
back in the skull cap no glasses
compared to the frames and the different
hat he wore on the train so far we see
like two Furies there's a lower status
humbler Fury outfit and the more pointed
confrontational look where he's got
lenses with special infrared sensors
where you might be able to like detect
more things about people a news Montage
shows Cub news a fictional Outlet in the
MCU that appeared on screens in Sword HQ
and Wanda Vision we learned some of the
world leaders currently in the MCU UK
prime minister Pamela Lawton NATO
Secretary General Sergio caspani who
seems to be that suited government
figure who appears in the opening title
imagery and then fxn news probably a
version of Fox News no doubt hosted by
Chris Sterns a pundit in the vein of
Sean Hannity played by Christopher
McDonald who played Shooter McGavin and
Happy Gilmore between him and Bradley
Whitford as Peggy Carter's boss from 90s
Adam Sandler comedies playing MCU
I love it graphic tells that he
wanted to see just how much of Fury was
left it's just Vapors
old which recalls Fury's dusting that we
flash back to last episode that at the
end of the infinity War like Sony
fallsworth graphic is saying that moment
changed Fury forever that not all of the
spymaster faded back you don't punish
The Man by giving him what he wants yes
and I'm sorry to link everything back to
Thanos but it does recall
the start of end game trying to punish
the Mad Titan by giving him the death
the punishment of Zemo refusing to let
him die at the end of Civil War as they
pull up to the building again we see
purple lighting mixed in with the green
tones of the street and the car visor
give this setting the green and purple
tone of the squirrel's skin and blood
and inside it's all Green Green carpet
green wallpaper not even trying to hide
their true colors we meet the scroll
Council which includes the UK prime
minister the NATO Secretary General and
the media pundit plus two others Shirley
cigar and Christopher go play in a
character credited as Jack hook bin
maybe a celebrity or a tech leader of
some kind I assume we'll find out in
future episodes in the secret Invasion
Comics several politicians and public
figures including Barack Obama John
McCain and Stephen Colbert are confirmed
to be Scrolls graphic accuses them of
drinking man's wine Gaia told Beto last
episode that they drink scroll line yet
we saw graphic plopping three cubes of
human
in his tea but he then sipped the tea so
maybe he was just wasting it Graphics
says he prefers dogs to humans because
they don't lock each other up in cages
they don't pimp poison they don't go out
of their way to degrade and destroy
their own habitat a naive reading of
human history it's the only reason human
history what an indictment Ultron came
to the same conclusion remember it's
interesting how grabbing nods to the
conservative media pundit for lock each
other up in cages as that guy's talking
points would have defended mass
incarceration most likely and as a
resident a new skrillos and an
irradiated nuclear plant gravity can see
how destructive human industry is but
you know really you should blame the
Extraterrestrial Eternal fastos for that
one graphic makes his case in a scroll
language but then switches back to
English for I think it's a war
I wonder if the English word for war is
more powerful than squirrel word for it
since the Scrolls lost their resistance
against the cree the NATO Secretary
General asks and what happens if the
Avengers return you don't think I
thought about that yes he's referring to
his super scroll program to make groots
called obsidian's extremist soldiers and
frost Giants out of themselves we'll
learn more about that later the UK prime
minister nominates graphic to the
wartime leader position scroll General
like Senator Binks nominated in Senator
Palpatine to have emergency wartime
powers and now graphic and thanks to
Rocket money for sponsoring today's vid
it makes saving money easy rocket money
used to be true bill but true bill
mutated from a bill management app into
a full-on money management Powerhouse
rocket money rocket money does
everything true bill did and more
helping 3.4 million members take control
of their finances with easy to use
features that put you back in charge of
your finances one of Rocket money's best
features is that it helps you find and
cancel all your unwanted subscriptions I
was wasting hundreds of dollars every
month on stuff I didn't even use and now
I can use rocketmoney's Smart savings
account to put that money aside instead
I just choose the amount I want to save
and how frequently rocket money
automatically deposits my money into a
savings fund that I can withdraw from
anytime for the money I'm spending
instead of saving I use the budgeting
tool it monitors my spending by category
sends notifications when I've exceeded
my spending limits and visualizes my
spend to earn ratio by month quarter or
year rocket money can even negotiate
bills from internet service bills to
cable and phone bills I didn't even know
those could be negotiated just upload a
photo of your bill and Rocket money does
the rest once you've signed up you can
unlock even more features in premium
it's so easy to use and there's no
reason not to take control of your
finances to try rocket money out for
free and support our Channel head to
rocketmoney.com new rockstars or click
the link in the video description but
interesting graphic allows Shirley to
leave unharmed despite her dissension
which indicates that he knows Talos will
learn about this and probably wants to
draw Talos out graphic returns to the
new scrollos radioactive shanty town to
a hero's welcome and he's tells this one
woman without you this wouldn't be
possible yeah I feel like he's actually
doing this for Gaia like I kind of David
koresh cult Vibe going on here like
maybe he's grooming another younger
female to make Gaia feel less important
either way I don't think he really means
when he says that without her he
couldn't done this Gaia sees how gravic
is keeping her out of the loop she
follows him and pagon into an old
reactor plant control room looking a lot
like the one at Chernobyl here they are
building these energy fields and I
assume will radiate skulls into Super
Scrolls the process is being overseen by
a couple named the Daltons there is a
Charles Dalton in the comics who's a
member of the mi-13 who becomes a
political liaison for shield I'm not
sure if it's connected but Dalton and
pagon talk about the failure of the
recent harvests which the subtitles
capitalize the H on suggesting that the
squirrels see this process of gathering
donor DNA as a kind of sacred process
maybe something that they have a divine
right to Brody gets grilled by the other
heads of state the final photos they
have on fury on the screen include one
of Fury when he was younger judging by
the jacket looks like a publicity still
from Avengers Age of Ultron and let's
quickly break down his dossier his
aliases include nicknames listed on his
Wiki page Nick Fury 100 red blooded
Earth man and Mr furry foxtrot Jacob
Veach which is an alias Nick Fury used
for a holding company in Captain America
Winter Soldier then one eyed man son of
a and the most dangerous man we
also see his associations which include
the US army shield CIA Project Pegasus
remember that was the tesseract research
project we started the beginning of 2012
Avengers and in Captain Marvel and Nick
Fury's crew which was the nickname of
Fury's post Shield Associates that we
saw in Age of Ultron I want to quickly
thank our team of researchers including
Mt Eric Francisco Gina Polito George
Morris and Noah chin for helping me id
these and a lot of other cool stuff in
this breakdown prime minister Lawton
wears a green necklace these squirrels
cannot help but show off their Verdigris
I'm gonna assume that everyone wearing
green flare on this Deus like the leader
to the left of France that African
leader behind Italy these guys ain't
just Irish Wayne Brody doubts the
Russian Intel the Diplomat from Slovakia
respectfully prime minister I can't take
the authenticity of Russian supplied
photos at face value
the Viking rolls the ties at me one more
time I'm going to put on the suit and
carpet vomit Brody went from the calm
voice of reason and Tony starkson at
hearings in Iron Man 2 2 speaking like
the boom boom phase one Iron Man himself
Brody reminds Fury that his other suit
is made of titanium the war machine suit
branched from the Iron Man line at the
heavily armored Mark II phase and at
that point Tony was still building his
suits from a gold titanium alloy at the
tavern Fury has changed back into his
business mode attire glasses in the
fedora hat remember these are the super
spy glasses with augmented displays and
infrared scanners so Fury might be
wearing them to detect things like an
elevated heart rate to see if Roadie is
lying about being a squirrel and that
also might be why Nick Fury was wearing
the glasses with Talos earlier on the
train he's only wearing them when he's
trying to figure out the secrets of the
person he's talking to Rody threatens to
hand Fury back over the Russians if
you're getting your rank here Colonel
Rose now Nick Fury's rank in the Army
was Colonel but presumably former Shield
director and current saber director
might outrank whatever Road he is at
this moment we
security advisor maybe Secretary of
Defense because he doesn't really have
the charm or the diplomacy of a U.N
Ambassador hang on Toby Ziegler is
Secretary of State Roadie serves Fury of
bourbon which Fury told fallsworth last
episode was his drink of choice and fury
warns Rudy about a Global Network of
spies Hydra yeah if Hydra was a bunch of
green guys who could shape-shift into
your daddy yes Hydra would be the go-to
Assumption because that was the network
they all had to deal with and Captain
America the Winter Soldier Hydra went on
to be nasty threats in Agents of Shield
but as of Age of Ultron the hydro threat
was thought to be mostly dealt with in
the MCU though in later episodes what if
the implication is that the Zola
algorithm might still be living on in a
computer terminal in Siberia Brody
indicates that he's known about Scrolls
for a while though about 15 years ago I
was part of an
Eyes Only top secret presentation so 15
years prior would be around 2010 2011 if
we assume that this show is set in 2025
to 2026 so this presentation that Rhodey
saw would be after Roadie became War
Machine as he was transitioning into his
Iron Patriot role for the government
that we saw in Iron Man 3. chances are
if Rody knew about Scrolls so did Tony
Stark so is rhodia scroll well in my
view he still highly scroll suspicious
but I think if the show planned to later
reveal him as a scroll they would have
left some breadcrumb In This Moment
besides this fairly by the books
government Intel backstory really the
big arguments against Roadie being a
scroll are one he was incapacitated in
Civil War and likely would have reverted
then and two if the MCU were to say
rhodey's heartbreak at the moment of
Tony Stark's death and end game wasn't
the real Roadie in that moment that just
might be stomping on sacred ground for
too many MCU fans and I just don't think
a hypothetical scene of the real Roadie
waking up from a fracking pod to Fury
telling him the Tony's dead and then
reacting then will hit his hard to MC
viewers then that moment in the end game
especially since we're learning a lot of
people are not watching this show and
Adventures in game is like one of the
top three biggest movies of all time
Roadie mentions that the squirrels sent
a few light ships crashing down to earth
this might be the answer to a long
running MCU mystery of what that ship
was that crashed into the ocean at the
end of Age of Ultron that wasn't Hulk in
the quinjet one of our tick boys flagged
this
splashed down in the bond of sea could
be the quinjet
what was Stark Stealth Tech we still
can't track the damn thing so presumably
this could have been one of the scroll
Cruisers like the one that brought Bruce
Banner back to get a son that we saw in
She-Hulk Fury explains why calling the
Avengers is a bad idea no no no no we
can't jump the gun on that you know we
get them in a fight with the Scrolls and
next thing you know they find themselves
duplicated and turned into terrorists
and I
so much it's been my favorite moment on
the show so far and it's mostly for how
real these two men get with each other
every ounce of power we wrestle from the
vice grip of the mediocre Alexander
pierces who run this world has earned in
blood yeah shots fired and he's totally
right Alexander Pierce sucked as a
leader part of their backstory was that
in Bogota Pierce planned to negotiate
with Rebels who freaking kidnapped his
daughter and only Fury's heroic plan to
rescue her is the reason he got back
alive and that's what put fury on the
path to becoming director of Shield but
Roadie shoots back to Fury's request to
help a brother out saying that the point
of their opportunities to hold each
other accountable when they fail it he
fires Fury both of these men are
stubborn and both of them are coming
from rational places James Rhodes
talking as a company man that he has
always been in this universe trying to
affect change from within the system and
Nick Fury being the guy who has always
been on the outside and that's where
he's been most effective as he says here
I'm Nick Fury
even when I'm out
I'm in hell yes this has really been
what Furious wanted to yell at everyone
on the show just because he's been
off-world on saber doesn't mean he's out
of the game and in fact he's very much
playing the game so volsworth picks the
lock of the Russian butcher shop and
correctly applies a scrawled test of
severing Brogan's finger in addition to
the skin turning green I like how the
dripping blood turns purple now it is
possible that fallsworth is herself a
scroll she could just be testing to find
out everything Brogan told the Russians
she is wearing green here but I think if
she is a scroll she probably does not
belong to Graphics group she would be a
scroll playing her own game so we're all
going to keep a close eye on Sonya Falls
where guy that sneaks around the scroll
base and in the background is a painting
of an old Soviet leader I think this
might be Constantine chernenko who is
only Secretary General from April of
1984 to March 1985 suggesting that this
plant might have been decommissioned
just a year or two before the Chernobyl
incident in 1986. broza Dalton's file
lists active pod number 19 which might
be referring to what fracking pod the
human version of Rosa Dalton is stored
in but then the big MCU Easter eggs this
episode come right here the samples of
Marvel Creed features the Scrolls have
been harvesting DNA from starting with
Groot listed as species floor Colossus
humanoid plant Planet X that was groots
listed Homeworld and Guardians of the
Galaxy now the image says that this
sample was acquired from Earth so
presumably this could have been
recovered from the Battle of wakanda or
the Battle of Earth in New York then
Frost Beast yotenheimensei carnivorous
repto mammal we saw these Frost beasts
and yotenheim in the first Thor movie
and then in the events of 2013's Thor
the Dark World a frost Beast was
transported to Earth from the events of
the convergence so presumably this is
that same one call obsidian species
unknown remember call obsidian that was
thanos's beefy minion in the black order
in Infinity War whose arm got chopped
off by Wong via a portal and then hacky
sacked by Bruce Banner this photo seems
to be showing that same severed hand on
ice and then extremists found from
humans on Earth remember them they were
the fiery combustible limb regenerating
test subjects of Aldrich Killian and
Iron Man 3. one of whom recently showed
up again in the fighting Club in chongqi
all of these lists Terra as c53 3 which
was Earth's planetary designation as of
Captain Marvel and all of their DNA is
listed as deoxyribonucleic acid-based
deoxyribonucleic acid DNA suggesting
though that there might be some beans in
the universe out there that are not
based in DNA and would be impossible for
Scrolls to replicate for example do
eternals have synthetic DNA could a
scroll replicate a Celestial does that
gooey Dope From quantumania veb have DNA
just an interesting thing to think about
carbon versus silicon-based life forms
now of course the plot here is the
generation of super skulls which in the
comics are Scrolls that can replicate
both the appearance and the powers of
enhanced beings and it could be possible
here that the specific creatures chosen
aren't just random that they start to at
least line up with a power similar to
those of the Fantastic Four who are
among the superheroes that the Scrolls
replicate in the comics like Groot can
stretch out like Reed Richards does
extremist fires up like Johnny Storm
does Cole obsidian is roughly the power
set of Ben Grimm and the parallel kind
of drops off after that I don't know I
just thought it'd be cool if they had
Ava star's DNA ghost from Ant-Man the
WASP so that one of these abilities
could be invisibility and phase shifting
to line up with Sue storm but there
could be others we'll see okay
fallsworth and Jack's broken with a
serum that boils his blood which is a
bit similar to how extremist Works while
squirrels are resistant to radiation
this could be one thing that disrupts
their inner chemistry Brogan confesses
that the Daltons are leading the science
for the super Scrolls program if also
worth seems to be more aware of this
operation just wants a name to confirm
her suspicions Graphics shoots the
Russian guard right as he was on the
downward swing to chop the sausage I
guess kind of like how Indiana Jones in
the Last Crusade times his clanging in
the Venice Library floor with that
librarian stamping the books it's just
weird how gravic holds a doorbell well
but that guard did completely fall back
into the shelves and made a huge crash
sound so I don't know who he's getting
here and as graphic slatters them in
like the meat carcasses that surround
them fallsworth goes down the escape
hatch
Dostoyevsky referring to dostoyevsky's
best known work crime and punishment in
which the character raskolnikov murders
an elderly pawn broker steals her Wares
and Must Escape down into the floor and
back to his own small apartment so
fallsworth knows that she's dooming
broken to death here because his Scrolls
will assume he talked as they extract
broken Gaia hides in the alley speaking
Russian into the phone likely reporting
the location of their Scrolls safe house
so graphic will assume it was broken who
told them and kill Brogan which would
piss off pagon who initiated Brogan and
wanted to keep him alive which I guess
is gaia's plan for further driving a
wedge between gravic and pagon after
earlier overhearing pagons say our
fearless leader isn't always right as I
pointed out before with the opening
credits imagery the bishop transitions
into the queen and transitions into the
king and it's all happening on one side
of the chessboard the scroll side in the
final sequence of the episode Fury
drives out to a home in the UK
Countryside where his skrull wife
Priscilla Fury I believe Vara from the
opening scene chops foods that are all
green if this is Vara I think we can
assume that Fury knows his wife is a
scroll even though she was reverts to
human form when he walks through the
door Fury did mention having a wife and
Winter Soldier but we didn't know if he
was telling the truth or not back then
my wife kicked me out
didn't know you were married
a lot of things you don't know about me
in their house as he walks in are
abstract paintings of humans taking
different forms reminding us of a scroll
mid transformation also interesting how
the books on the shelves all seem to be
arranged by color like there's a blue
shelf a green shelf an orange shelf a
red shelf like the show itself in the
color coordinated Scrolls whoever put
these books on the Shelf is very color
coordinated but of all the different
disguises Fury wears this episode The
disguise of an unmarried man is the one
that Fury must drop when he comes home
like superheroes wearing masks to
protect those they love Fury keeps his
wedding ring off to prevent any enemies
thinking he has a wife and going out
looking for her Otis Redding's Try a
Little Tenderness plays 60s Soul music
always being a favorite of Furies after
he cited the Marvel let's wait a minute
Mr Postman and Captain Marvel and as
this episode Fades to Black Otis
Redding's lyrics say squeezer don't
tease her never leave her had Fury left
his wife behind on Earth while he was on
saber or did she join him on that space
station was she this
got my shoes Fury maybe it was just your
wife clean it up after you hey subscribe
to new rockstars and the Deep dive and
the break room which is where our secret
Invasion after shows inside Marvel will
now live and it can support us by
grabbing some merch like this secret
Invasion inspired scroll design and nerd
riot.shop follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at hey boss follow me rockstars
And subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis everything you love thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]